Welcome, everybody, to another Zoom call.
We're going to jump into questions that were submitted.
But remember, if you have other questions, you can put them in the chat.
Or you can unmute yourself when we're done answering the questions that were submitted.
And you can verbalize your question.
Reminder again that all announcements will be in the member site.
Last week we did not have a Zoom call that announcement up here.
So just look at that for your any new things.
Okay, let's jump into the questions.
First question, is there a test to measure toxins in our drinking water?
That's a good question. I actually just talked to somebody about testing for glyphosate in their drinking water.
You can do so.
You know, you can test more toxins, certain toxins in any water supply.
But typically when people are asking to test their water supply, they're asking to test their well water.
Though you could test any water, I suppose, because who knows if you're sitting with a spality is testing for things, right?
But the well water testing that can be done through the county, like we just had our water tested last year, I think it was maybe the year before through the county.
They test for I think heavy metals, they test for nitrates, sulfides, things like that, nitrates, and things like that.
And that's really the extent that they test for maybe like six different things.
So then you're at, okay, how do I test for other toxins in my water?
I don't know, you'd have to Google any labs that test for other toxins.
I do know that Louisiana does have a glyphosate test so that you can get a water glyphosate test.
So many of you through us had your urine tested for glyphosates.
That's how that's your glyphosate count in you.
But then you go, let's say it was really high in your question, where like the exposed to glyphosates, then you could test your drinking water.
So Louisiana lab has a glyphosate test for your own water.
I know I ordered that for a person today, so that is a test that you can run.
That was far as testing for other different contaminants and toxins.
I personally don't know of any labs that do that, though, I'm sure they're baby, some out there.
And, but I never looked at them, so you have to Google it.
Test for a glyphosate, we've contacted us.
It's not that expensive, but it's like $120 or something like that to test for glyphosate.
Let's go back to that question.
What would you do if you had toxins in your water or if you suspected toxins?
Let's see, I'm supposed to have toxins in the water.
I don't want to spend the money on the test.
I'd rather spend the money on the fix.
Well, typically, reverse osmosis would be the way to go to get a reverse osmosis using it in your house.
And depending on where you live, you know, typically you can rent those.
I don't call a good water as that you can rent.
Echo water is another system that I think is a little bit better than the elegant water system, but I don't know if they rent those.
So you can contact water softener type company.
Many times they will have reverse osmosis units, they will come and install them.
I do do know you can buy a reverse osmosis unit in a big box store like a binards or home depot or something like that, but I don't recommend that there's far inferior.
I would get the call of good water, the echo water one.
I think at this office, we read the call of good one. I think it's like 30 bucks a month.
So that's something to look into is glutamic acid good to take to help yield the gut.
So typically, when you're healing the gut, you would do glutamine.
So what's the difference with me and glutamic acid?
Well, both are amino acids.
But glutamic acid will convert to glutamine and glutamine will convert to glutamic acid.
So there's not a whole lot, but they technically are different.
So glutamic acid is an acid. It has a carboxy group, which makes it an acid, but they do convert back and forth.
The negative of taking glutamine for a cancer patient is that glutamine can upregulate cell reproduction, which is great to help heal the gut.
But it's a negative for a cancer patient because it upregulates cell reproduction.
You don't want to do that with a cancer patient.
The other negative of glutamic acid and or glutamine in a product is that they are also readily converted to glutamate.
To glutamate, the glutamate is a neurotransmitter.
So the glutamates are excitatory neurotransmitters.
And you do need them.
Your body will convert glutamic acid and glutamine through several genes.
One of them is the GAT-GAT gene to glutamate in order to make enough neurotransmitters, you need neurotransmitters.
However, the problem usually entails people making too much glutamate because of too much glutamine and having defects in the GAT gene.
It's very readily convert glutamate to glutamate.
And as our food supply typically has a lot of glutamates, we have the problem that we have is not typically too little glutamate.
It's most commonly too much glutamate, too high of a concentration of glutamates.
The glutamate found in foods is monosodium glutamate and MSG, but glutamic acid is also an excitatory neurotransmitter itself.
And it's used in foods.
So a lot of times you'll see glutamate acid is an additive in foods because they don't want to list MSG because people have a negative connotation of MSG, which they should.
Because excess MSG is going to cause excess glutamate in the brain, it causes excitatory increase excitatory or transmitters in the brain, which can cause OCD, anxiety, depression, all sorts of issues, brain issues, increased brain inflammation.
It's a very nasty player.
So people with any type of brain inflammation, people with any type of brain issues whatsoever, meaning they have early Parkinson's, they have depression, they have anxiety, they have OCD issues, they have dementia issues, they should stay away from excitatory neurotransmitters.
They should stay away from glutamic acid, they should stay away from glutamates, and they should stay away from doing anything that's going to increase inflammation of the brain, they should stay away from dyes, food dyes.
It's got to look at testing for food sensitivities and stay away from anything that is causing an increase inflammation.
So is glutamic acid good to help heal the gut? Well, glutamine would be the source of the gut healing product, not glutamic acid, because this glutamic acid would convert to glutamate quicker than glutamine would.
That the answer to this question will be don't.
Second answer to this question, even if you're taking glutamine to help heal the gut, I would say don't.
Is glutamine okay to take for somebody to heal the gut who doesn't have cancer? Yes, but still in low concentrations.
There are some products that you buy over the market that's a powder that has, you're taking five grams of glutamated that to heal the gut.
Well, I guess taking an issue for a very short period of time would be okay, but excess, it's still going to convert to glutamate, but more readily if people have anxiety, defects.
And it's going to cause all sorts of emotional issues, so I would still be very careful of that.
Next question. Oh, it is this question. Oh, I don't like to see that first question, second, third question.
Is passing any gas at all after a meal or ever a sign of leaky gut? How much gas is too much?
No, I wouldn't say that having gas is a sign of leaky gut.
If you never pass gas, I would say that's probably not normal. It's normal for you to have some level of fermentation of food in your gut creating gas that you'll have to pass.
So it's never normal to not have gas. How much gas is too much?
Well, I wouldn't say it's a sign of leaky gut, but if you have excess gas, like, oh my gosh, I have so much gas.
I don't know what's wrong with me. It's this is way more than normal for me would be a sign of maldigestion.
So that can also company leaky gut, but it wouldn't be a sign of leaky gut itself.
So maldigestion is because food isn't being properly digest. Usually it's a deficiency in a fight or for a gas and an insufficiency in painkrantic enzymes.
So you're not properly digesting your foods and you're getting, you know, excess fermentation of your foods and you're getting excess gas production.
The treatment, quote unquote, for that would be to increase HCl with each meal and painkrantic enzymes with your meals to help you break down your food.
That's basically what products like beetle, you know, that are they're just digestive enzymes.
So taking digestive enzymes and HCl would be the treatment. You feel like you have excess gas.
Also making sure you're having bowel movements. Some people have very slow digestive tracks that are not having bowel movements and their intestinal transit time is very slow.
You want to make sure that you support that as well. Go back to the 7 phases of detoxification course.
It will help you with this question too. Is it okay that the bulb heats up very use? I know my wife, oh, does I just wasn't sure if the Attilia Robin bulb does this as well.
Yeah, all the bulbs will heat up. The Attilia Robin bulb will probably heat up less now when you're ready.
My programs because my programs all contain the 11th about it. So it's going to heat up the last plus the new Attilia Robin bulb is larger.
So it's going to heat up less than the right. But that still is.
I remember you speaking about the harmonics on it. That's on the Attilia Robin, but cannot find your teaching explanation of what.
That is and what it means. Remember you are looking for something you can look on our website and search the word harmonics. I don't know if I have a blog post on that.
But certainly on our video page if you searched harmonic or harmonics, but sometimes take the plural.
You'll find a couple videos that I did on harmonics on our video site.
But in general, harmonics is actually a musical term when they're talking about frequencies, but it is a term when you talk about physics of a harmonic of a frequency.
Or harmonic is a multiple of a frequency. So let's say you're ready to frequency of three hertz.
The first harmonic would be six hertz. The second harmonic would be nine hertz. The third harmonic would be 12 hertz. The 11th harmonic would be 36 hertz, because it's 11 times that.
33 hertz. So that's what a harmonic. So when we're running the when we're ready 11th harmonic, why are we already the 11th harmonic? What's the significance.
It was just found in some testing that running the 11th harmonic of a frequency that is known to kill let's say a pathogen or known to kill a cancer cell and you run the 11th harmonic of that frequency at the same time that the kill rate is so much higher.
And I do share there's a video of data practitioner, but a physicist, I think he's out in Georgia, sharing it on a 10 talk.
There's a video on our website about that.
He was killing all the paradesium or something with frequency and then when he added the 11th harmonic of that frequency, completely destroyed, blew up the paradesium.
Or it was a bacteria. I can't remember in the video. I've watched it for a long time. But so that's what the benefit of harmonics is and that's why I like that till you're rather because you can run a harmonic at the same time.
So there's different programs that I've written that have the harmonics written in them, certainly all the pathogen programs, anything that you're trying to kill, maybe the organism, anytime you try to kill cancer, you're using the elements of harmonic frequency.
Is it okay to change the length of time under the dwell number if we want to extend the heli time?
Well, yes, it's funny because I've been using right for gosh 20 plus years 25 years.
It's only the second time I've gotten this question in the first time I got this question was like three weeks ago.
So it tells me that our patients are getting smarter. That's what tells me.
So yes, so the dwell time in the program itself. So when you're looking at the program running where it says the different codes in the program or you could see it says things like pulse and dwell and and that those are commands under the dwell that might say 180 that means it's going to dwell on the following frequencies until the dwellers change for 180 seconds.
Each frequency if you wanted to change the length of the time let's say the program was an hour long program and you wanted to make it a two hour program.
Well, you could play with it and change the dwell on it and hit run and it's like, oh no, it's an hour and a half. Well, then up the dwell again, hit run.
Oh, there it's two hours that you could hit save and now you save that program with that different dwell.
Really negative of you playing with it is.
You do risk messy enough. So but if you feel confident and I'm just changing the dwell of you're not going to hurt anything and if you don't hit save.
You, you know, you and you go out of the program and go back in it, it wouldn't have been saved. So it will be back to the original program.
It would only change the program if you hit save. So if you hit dwell and you change the dwell on a program and then you hit run and all that's the perfect time for me because I, you know, whatever that's the time you want.
Then I would just hit save and now you'll have that program saved all the time.
So yes, you can do that.
Is there a score healing program? If so, is it okay to use after surgery?
I don't know. Remember if there's a score.
I don't know. You can look up if there is.
I know there's just healing programs. I know there's there may be connected tissue programs.
I don't know. I apologize. You have to look under the alphabetical listing of things that you would wound.
You know, some synonym of that if you don't see scholar.
Our 11th harmonics attached slash included in my personal programs.
Preset frequencies.
Or are they only in other pathogen killing points.
So there is on the atelier robin is the only. So if you have two rights, this doesn't exist. This doesn't exist. But only till you're robin, we can run along the harmonics.
And originally I wrote a set of pathogen programs that are in the folder that says 11th harmonic pathogen kill programs.
Well, those are just common pathogen kill programs in that folder in the alphabetical listing of all the programs that are in there.
All of them that it's relevant to have an 11th harmonic is written an 11th harmonic. I wrote every single one of those programs. So if it if I believe that it would have been beneficial to have 11th harmonic.
Okay, if you're running something that like let's say an inflammation program, there's not really any benefit to run the 11th harmonic in inflammation.
But that isn't written in the 11th harmonic.
But if it's any type of pathogen kill or a cancer program, then it's written in the 11th harmonic. So you don't have to use that folder.
And yes, all your personal preset frequencies are all in the 11th harmonic.
So because we're talking to cancer people with cancer, so you have a diagnosis cancer, your cancer program is written in the 11th harmonic.
And remember, if you have an until you're robin and you wouldn't be asking this question if you didn't, but if you also have a true right, you cannot use these programs on your true right personally, they won't work.
But if you had an older true right with let's say version five, they could possibly work with you're going to burn out the machine.
So with version six point four, they won't run.
But with a version six or earlier, they may run, you're just going to work, you're just going to fry the sheet.
So it won't work.
So the two machines are not compatible program wise.
So you can't run true right programs on the until you robin or could you run the until you robin programs on the true right.
Next question. What should be my next step in this journey? I bet I might protocol and then then since June 1st, more blood testing or another test.
Feeling great, but kind of confused.
Well, we can talk number one. So you can set up a time when we could chat. That could be a possibility.
Number two, remember, if you're unfendman, and it has affected your liver enzymes, you should consider getting another comprehensive metabolic profile to make sure it isn't making things worse.
Again, that should be in the mix.
Number three, doing another cheek swab test would be a possibility too.
So I do have a video. This is a good question. Like, when should I do another cheek swab or when should I do another lab?
Number one, if I didn't tell you, if you don't remember me telling you you need to do with other lab this much time, then you can ask on this forum here.
It's a good place to ask a question like this. You could make an appointment and ask about next steps.
Well, too often we see people just just kind of follow up. They feel great and they just disappear.
And then we don't know whatever happened to the green one like, oh my gosh, whatever happened in this person, we haven't heard from them for months. They call them and, oh, I'm doing great.
Well, that's good. We don't want you to feel like you have to connect to us.
But we also don't want you to fall through the cracks and not get labs when we should get labs too.
Because, you know, something could be going on and we want to make sure we're staying on top of that.
Especially if your appointment is all that hypervector, you want to make sure that it's not affected your liver negatively.
Because you may not feel what a quote the effects liver toxicity until something drastic happens.
So getting a blood test as long as you're open-possed AST, ALT and with the normal limits.
And you're doing great that there isn't really any, I would tell you, there really is a need to do a cheek swab test that will keep going.
That's a problem. We just want to make sure there's not any toxicity going on in your liver that you're not comprehending it.
Question from the chat.
Regarding the cheek swab test, if you can say, what would cause a need to increase tumouric to the smoothie?
In other words, what are we treating by increasing tumouric?
So understand, what do I do with cheek swab test?
Sometimes people will go, how come you took that out?
How come you told me to stop this?
Or how come you reduce that from four a day to two a day?
Or then how come you increase this one from two a day to four a day?
So in the cheek swab test, I'm just reading what's coming out when I'm doing the test.
Now, I could try to understand that from a physiological standpoint, metabolic standpoint,
well, why would we increase tumouric?
Why would we decrease this product?
Well, we might decrease the product because your body is saturated with it.
You don't need any more to that.
We might increase the product because you need more of the benefits that that product does.
What does tumouric do in the body?
Well, tumouric itself can be a cancer killer directly.
I bet you, you know, I bet you there's a thousand articles on Google.
Maybe a thousand pages of articles on Google about the benefits of tumouric for cancer.
I'm not exaggerating.
So whoever tumouric is currently mid.
So doing so increasing tumouric for cancer patient can be cancer killing the direct cancer killer.
In general, for an uncancer patient, what's the benefits of tumouric?
It's an anti-inflammatory.
So it's a flammatory and it's going to decrease inflammation.
So you could say tumouric is good for everybody.
Certainly good for brain inflammation.
Certainly good for just overbody inflammation.
So it's whatever came up on the test, doesn't mean that some people go,
will you had me increase this?
Does that mean I'm doing worse?
No, it doesn't.
I'm not quantitatively saying a person is doing better or worse.
It's just telling me what your body needs and stuff.
Next question from the chat.
Do you have any thoughts on the signature test?
I thought I read that it picks up remaining circulating tumour cells that are dead from the original tumour.
Well, the signature test is picking up DNA, circulated tumour, DNA.
Is it picking up dead to circulated tumour cells?
No, not to my knowledge.
It's picking up circulated tumour cells that are not dead.
Is that a good thing to measure?
Well, some people use it as a measurement of whether the person is doing better or worse.
So they're doing a signature test.
The measure, if the person has a decrease in circulated tumour cells,
then the practitioner may interpret that by saying the patient is doing better.
If they have an increase in circulated tumour cells,
the practitioner may interpret that as the patient is doing worse.
However, if you really think about the physiology of that,
to me, that doesn't quite.
And the reason is because a cancer doesn't give off...
There's no data that says the cancer gives off more circulated tumour cells as it's growing.
There's times that it gives off more circulated tumour cells,
but it doesn't necessarily...
It's not a one-to-one equation that the cancer is growing,
or it's a one-to-one correlation that a decrease in circulated tumour cells means the cancer is dying.
So I don't see value in doing a signature test because the data...
It's just confusing.
It doesn't give us adequate data to say the person is doing better or worse.
So it doesn't...
Again, you do a test if it's giving you data on how you're going to change the treatment of the patient.
So if it's not giving you adequate data on objectively whether the person is doing better or worse,
or needs to change in the treatment plan, then I don't see any value in spedding the money and running the test.
So that's why I don't run that test.
So that's my opinion.
I don't think it's adequate objective data that would warrant me changing the treatment plan on a patient.
Next question.
Is it true that if eacidophils are over three, it means the presence of a parasite?
No.
So elevated eacidophils, can that be parasitic?
It can be.
Can that be an allergic reaction like from pollen?
It's not specific solely to one thing.
It gives you clues.
Every lab you do, it gives you clues.
And so if a person has elevated white blood cells and elevated eacidophils,
you'd want to match that with their history and to get an idea.
If they have a history of no allergies whatsoever,
and they have a history of current gut issues that you could take.
Well, maybe we should treat for parasites, but they have a history of no gut issues.
And they have a history of a lot of hyper allergies and environmental toxicity issues.
Then you think that it's probably from environmental issues and allergies and you may treat completely different.
So you use blood work in ways that it's giving you information.
It's giving you data, it's giving you objective information to guide you along your treatment plan.
Just like in the last question, oh, I have elevated DNA circulating to ourselves.
Well, does that should we change our whole protocol?
Should we now go on Kina?
No, that doesn't really tell us any data.
It gives us maybe a little bit of a clue, but it's so minor that I wouldn't spend the money on that test.
To do an eacidophil test at a CBC with a differential that's going to give you a white blood cell count
and a differential and the different types of white blood cell count is very inexpensive.
And it gives you more data on how to treat the patient.
So that would be a better test, not necessarily cancer, but for whatever's going on.
So again, you use lab work to give you clues on what's going on so that you can best treatment the patient is objectively as possible.
Next question from the chat.
Do you have knowledge about standard process?
Then you complete pro muscle building and recovery powder to try and help build muscle and building muscle building and recovery rebuilding after cancer surgery and moving forward.
No, I don't, but I can look it up.
So it's in there.
Bad.
Complete.
Alright, so here it is.
It's a valuable source of several amino acids.
Organic P protein, pumpkin seed protein.
Sports muscle building.
What is it?
So.
Organic P protein, pumpkin seed protein, sesame seed protein, cocoa powder, coconut sugar, cashew flavor.
I don't see anything wrong with that.
You can try that.
Yeah.
It's got, um, maybe.
It's got 15 grams of protein per surveyed.
Yeah.
I don't see any problem.
You could try that.
One last question.
Next question from the chat.
Recently, when I take my clear digest, I get a birdie sensation.
Is it because I have low NHL or have adequate NHL?
Um, so if you're taking your clear digest right before your meal and you get a birdie sensation and you put something and then you eat something, then you're okay.
Wherever you only take clear digest when you're eating.
So if you're taking clear digest and empty stomach with nothing, your stomach, you can't get a birdie sensation.
Um, now that's typically a sign of stomach dysfunction.
And you may want to add some support, like GI sued to help heal your stomach line.
Um, but really before I would do that, I would just, you know, when you're going to take it, when you're going to eat, I would eat a couple bites of food, take my clear digest and then just keep eating.
Um, it may just because you're taking it on an empty stomach and it's irritating your gut because you don't have anything in your stomach.
And then when you eat, so I would just take it more mid meal will be more appropriate.
And if you're still having issue mid meal.
And then, then you probably have some.
A little bit of age, age point.
Laura boy done.
Look at my blog post on helical vector.
Pylori and how to treat that.
And hypochloridory and how to treat that.
Because if a person has stomach problems and peed when they take HCL, then they have to take a step back and use.
Um, so like a GI suit to help heal the stomach.
And instead of HCL, you have to take a step back and use apple cider vinegar as your acidifier.
But it's probably just because you're taking it to the empty stomach.
So before I would do that, I would just eat something, uh, eat a couple bites of food, then take your product and then keep eating.
So if yes, it fills are the low three.
Is that good news for the patient?
It's, yeah, I'm trying to remember the normal level of yes, it fills up the chapel by head.
So if they're within normal range, that's good news. But again, you could have parasites and not have any imbalance in your.
In your.
In your white blood cell coat, or any imbalance in your, um, uh, breakdown of white blood cells.
So optimal range of.
Especially if you're talking about eocidipil percentage or the absolute via sort of bills, optimal range of eocidipils 0.03 to 0.2.
If you're talking about, um, eocidipil percentage, or that's a percentage of the total white blood cell count, that it's 0 to 3 is optimal range.
So I think you're talking about percentage.
So if it's below three, it's within normal range, but it still does not in itself rule out the fact that a person could still have parasites.
So again, you don't just use, you know, use any type of test and say, well, this is conclusive that you don't have this or a conclusion that you do have this.
You have to take it in consideration of patients, objective, subjective, fight each other as done on history, etc.
So I hope that helps.
Alright, thank you all for participating today. Thanks for being on resume. Hopefully this is helpful.
But again, if you have any other questions, reach out to our clinic and we will be closed on the 4th of July.
I hope you guys have a last 4th of July and we'll talk again next week.
Bye bye.